voted my government into power for a
second term with an even stronger
mandate than before and it is thanks to
this mandate that I am standing here
before you once again however the
message that this mandate conveys has an
even greater significance a wider and
more inspiring one mr. president when a
developing country is able to
successfully implement the world's
biggest sanitation campaign within the
clean India mission building over a
hundred and ten million toilets in just
five years for its countrymen all its
achievements and outcomes are an
inspirational message for the entire
world when a developing country
successfully runs the world's biggest
health assurance scheme giving 500
million people the facility of an annual
health cover of 500 thousand rupees for
free treatment the achievements and
responsive systems that result from the
scheme show the world a new path when a
developing country successfully runs the
biggest Financial Inclusion scheme of
the world opening over 370 million bank
accounts for the poor in just five years
the systems that result build confidence
in the poor across the entire world when
a developing country
launches for its citizens the world's
biggest digital identification program
giving them a biometric identity
enabling them to avail their rights and
saving approximately twenty billion
dollars by checking corruption the
modern systems that result from it give
the world a new hope mr. president as I
came in here on a wall at the entrance
of this building I noticed the call to
make the United Nations free of
single-use plastic I am pleased to
inform this August assembly that even as
I am addressing you today a very large
campaign is being started across the
entire country to make India free of
single-use plastic in the next five
years in the next five years apart from
promoting water conservation we are
going to ensure water supply to 150
million homes in the next five years we
are going to build over 125,000
kilometres of new roads by the Year 2022
when India celebrates its 75th
Independence Day we plan to build 20
million houses for the poor
[Music]
though the world
may have set itself the target of
eradicating TB by 2030 in India we are
working towards eradicating it by 2025
the question that arises is just how
have we been able to achieve all of this
how is it that such rapid changes are
taking place in a new India mr.
president
India is a great culture that is
thousands of years old a culture that
has its own vibrant traditions and which
has encompassed universal dreams our
values and culture see divinity in every
being and strive for the welfare of all
therefore the very core of our approach
is public welfare through public
participation and this public fell
welfare is not just for India but for
the entire world and that is the reason
and that is the reason we draw
inspiration from our motto collective
efforts for the growth of all with
everyone's trust and this too is not
confined within the borders of India our
endeavors are neither an expression of
pity nor a pretense they are inspired by
a sense of duty and duty alone all our
endeavors are centered on 1.3 billion
Indians
but the dreams that these efforts are
trying to fulfill are the same dreams
that the entire world has that every
country has and that every society has
the efforts are ours but the fruits are
for all for the entire world and this
conviction of mine gets stronger every
day when I think of those countries who
just like India are striving for
development each in their own way when I
hear about their joys and sorrows when I
get to know about their dreams my
resolve to develop my country at a
faster pace gets even stronger so that
India's experience can be beneficial to
these countries also mr. president about
300 3000 years ago you know 3,000 years
ago a great part of India whose name was
Canyon Bumgarner he wrote in Tamil which
is the most ancient language of the
world he said ya Desmarais ya Varun
carried which pains we belong to all
places and we belong to everyone and
this is something that was said 3,000
years ago
this sense of belonging Beyond Borders
is unique to India in the last five
years India has worked towards
strengthening its centuries-old great
tradition of fraternity among nations
and working for the welfare of the world
which is indeed in line with the key
objectives of the United Nations the
issues that in their raises the kind of
new global platforms that India has come
forward to build seek collective efforts
to address serious global challenges and
issues mr. president if you look at it
from a historic and per capita emission
perspective India's contribution to
global warming is very low however India
is one of the leading nations when it
comes to taking steps to addressing this
issue on one hand we are working towards
achieving the target of 450 gigawatts of
renewable energy and on the other hand
we have also taken the initiative to
create the International solar Alliance
one of the effects of global warming is
the increasing number
severity of Natural Resources and not
just that at the same time they are
appearing in new areas and in new forms
in view of this India has initiated the
formation of the coalition for disaster
resilient infrastructure which is also
called CDR I this coalition is something
I invite all countries to join this
coalition will help build infrastructure
that can withstand natural disasters mr.
president the largest number of supreme
sacrifices made by soldiers of any
country for the UN peacekeeping missions
is from India we belong to a country
that has given the world not war but
Buddha's message of peace
obviously and that is the reason why our
voice against terrorism to alert the
world about this evil rings with serious
seriousness and outrage we believe that
this is one of the biggest challenges
not for any single country but for the
entire world and humanity the lack of
unanimity amongst us on the issue of
terrorism dents those very principles
that are the basis for the creation of
the UN and that is why for the sake of
humanity I firmly believe that it is
absolutely imperative that the world
unites
against terrorism and that the world
stands as one against terrorism mr.
president
the face of the world is changing today
modern technology in the 21st century is
bringing about sweeping changes in
social life personal life economy
security connectivity and in
international relations in such a
situation a fragmented world is in the
interest of no one neither do we have
the option to confine ourselves within
our boundaries
in this new era we will have to give new
direction to multilateralism and to the
United Nations we will need to give it
new strength mr. president
125 years ago the great spiritual guru
Swami Vivekanand gave this message to
the world during the world Parliament of
Religions
in Chicago right here in America the
message was harmony and peace and not
dissension today the message from the
world's largest democracy for the
international community is still the
same harmony and peace thank you all
very much